oh the college is even worse than that
it's always we have a student here is
really funny so he goes up there and
he's just murdering you guys you know
you ain't gonna catch Larry about its
goddamn bug yellow sweat pants on I said
I'm drunk I'm not stupid I don't live in
Turner hall I'm waking up with back pain
a lot lately the is dude talking
about
[Music]
I'm dance soda that's big Jay oakerson
bo burnham joining us his movie 8th
grade out now on blu-ray DVD on demand
on demand not gonna lie to you I haven't
seen it but I'm very excited to see got
a copy of it and eighth grade was
possibly one of the worst years of my
life and I've heard that if you had a
tough 8th grade year this is the movie
to see ya whatever la clue just watched
it loved it legit took him back to
appreciate man thank you all the time no
no I'm sure but I've cost more about
working with young people like that did
you find that here because we always
talk we watch movies me Christina and
Danny watch many times a young person
acting especially like the law and
orders
yeah oh well that's like you're just
like no I mean the kid themselves like I
bet I hate this kid as a real person I
bet with Sunil cut she's like where's my
diet that's right we for the most part
got like actual real kids from the
middle school that we film that from
that like there's a pool party seeing
half of the kids swim at that pool on
weekends so like they're monsters in
their own way you know is that they're
actually normal and they don't give a
about being in a day did they make
you ever feel like the thing that would
kill me from like a 13 year old if they
were like this guy takes things
too seriously
that would hurt me rather shut up
we had to tour a bunch of middle schools
and high schools to scout the thing to
get locations we would go through the
middle schools and it would be like it'd
be like like Dennis Rodman in North
Korea or something I mean if you'll
agree that just like people like coming
up to me and just like touching my
clothes and thank you
and then we stepped into our first high
school step into it and I heard hey bo
burnham I'm funny too you little bitch
we were like we're in high school it was
like actually incredibly thrilling like
and and working with middle schoolers
was very fun working with the high
schoolers was terrifying
like like 20 18 high schoolers looking
you feel like the biggest I'm looking at
like my like adidas pumps that I have on
I'm like I'm them what you're describing
I couldn't do it because of what all
you're doing is you're taking
testosterone of those kids and just
amplifying it like two notches and
they're coming in like I remember being
young and always afraid of the older
kids I'm like bigger people when I was
little and then I went to the same
school it was like it was kindergarten
through twelfth grade okay K through 12
I'll stay the whole time but I was in it
yeah K for 12 I didn't stay the whole
time
mm-hmm but um I remember I got so like
eighth or ninth grade and you were in
the different halls yeah I had to do
something in the halls of the younger
grades yeah and I went over there and
made a concerted effort when a kid
walked by be like by the way jerk off
you know and he went uh you would
you bitch and he he called my bluff
immediately and I was like I can't just
hit him in school guys like he wins like
I give three grades lower than me he was
like you what are you telling I was
gonna give us cow were like you're
supposed like I would have so when you
were two how much in the high schools
were you we were there only a few days
okay so you were getting out you're like
last day long these monsters yeah it was
but it was beautiful because it was like
we felt like the story we were telling
in there which is that like high school
is terrifying from an outsider from
either end you're coming from looking
back or looking forward it's it's
horrifying and they're just they're so
self-possessed now they're just they
just are cooler than they've ever been
because of Instagram they have like
hints is that they're just like really
really literate socially in a very quick
way that you're not in on and like
things being things are so old so quick
for kids now that like the the amount of
out-of-touch you are is just
exponentially bigger than it would have
been like you know Haiti is kids
relating to 90's kids it's like 2012's
kids relating to now
I'm a 2001 now I'm just gone my daughter
has excuse to have crushes on vine
celebrities yes and so when her mom will
say something about like I knew you know
celebrity crush Isabel has I go what is
it a vine celebrity she goes there is no
fine yeah what's the other one was the a
periscope but those things are coming to
clear Hughes another thing they're huge
that's wild these kids these musical
kids are built are born two thousand
three years after 9/11 yeah I and it's
in the movie actually but it's like in
the background there is a banner like of
the Twin Towers is it's a thing and it
was a school like 90 minutes north and
it's like oh that is a historical event
for them yeah that'd be like the way
they show like Washington Crossing the
Delaware like an on a patch look at that
that happened they go those used to be
the Twin Towers and you're like oh man I
remember what my record was on Mad in
that year I did a spot the comedy club
the night before yeah I I woke up yeah I
was a freshman in college and it's weird
to think that these kids are just like
that wasn't even do two years to that my
daughter was born 2002 yeah weird
post 9/11 kids yes I'm a Reagan baby
what's up yeah say no drugs
eighth grade I'm trying to remember
Christine said it was a fantastic year
for her you had a good eighth grade year
straight South Foley after that was
great I switched school so I went to one
school for grammar school til sixth
grade where I got like bullied and it
was just shitty and then I went to this
awesome school for seventh and eighth
grade where it was just it was like an
amazing school experience yeah small
classes the teachers gave a it was
like very community driven that's all
yeah that makes you feel better about
yourself yeah my first gay friends it is
incredible to to see how socially
progressive the schools are which I
think actually like colors the misery of
the kids in just a horrible dose of
irony the fact that like you're walking
by a poster that says like support trans
rights and you feel like a piece of
yeah I feel like for the first time like
the administration and the faculty and
your parents are constantly looking at
you hoping you're feeling good and you
still feel shitty it's like
they they would love to get a
swirly or have their head shoved in a
locker I would actually ground their
pain in something tangible that's it I
don't world is coddling me and I feel
empty inside why the I they have no
structure you know they have no
structure to so there anything to rage
in to fight again no is it really bad I
think is holy I think bullying was part
of the terrarium as part of the
UH I mean I remember the kid's body
system of growing up I think I was
bullied I was bullied and I eventually
stood up to a bully in my light not all
of them but you know I have that you
have that kind of check on viewless I've
bullied and and Ben got hurt by
the person I but you know I mean like
they hit me first or I lost the fight
you know I mean like it was all part of
like learning a thing and I knew I
didn't bully people after them yeah but
it's like but it's like it's bullying
this is just completely abstract some
instead of like I got my head shoved in
a locker it's like someone made a fake
Instagram account of oh yeah said I'm a
neocon as I weighed school prayer really
is and I was talking to kids about cuz
like it's incredible how much these kids
are think about politics and just have
to and they like lose friendships over
their political allegiances do in fact I
mean in eighth grade was I being like
you're a Dukakis kid like
you do I did like a little
roundtable with the kids and talking to
them and like this like 12 year old kids
gonna do you know what happened in Iran
and I'm like no it's it's it's it's
crazy is this is this kind of a symptom
from all the information being leaked in
towns where you can just read anymore in
a second where you just have to hear
someone from somebody and then that they
were your source I remember one time I
follow enough adults you're bound to
just as you're thumbing up the thing and
seeing like look at this burger I just
ate and I could have to crush this steak
there's eventually gonna be like a news
story and you're gonna you see fire and
troops do you click it and you read the
thing you know that but it yeah exactly
and it's also just like the whatever
like democratization of information all
this which is like we all thought
was like super cool that everyone is a
voice but now we have no way to discern
discern which voice is important
the hierarchy like true value or meaning
is in it and it literally is like
perfectly demonstrated in what a feed is
you scroll through your feet is your kid
you will see in no particular order your
mother your your friends the president
the United States
chick-fil-a I mean it's just like these
they're all being presented with the
same amount of space and yoga pants'
taking a picture in front of a mirror
yeah and it's and it's it's a lot to
process and for kids at the end of the
night to have to choose between like the
back of your eyelids or everything in
the history of the world you go you go
crazy couldn't I go crazy I started
pissing sitting down so I could be in my
phone like 18 months ago and I was like
something's wrong yeah you know like
this is and then I just it was just do
you think do you think cell phones are
gonna be kind of like the new cigarettes
we're only 20 years from now people like
you got to stay off cell phones you're
gonna get cable yeah and I always said
like it's going to be yeah it's gonna be
like smoking and we're gonna the
equivalent of my doctor used to smoke
will be like my shrink at atwitter yeah
it'll be so good you go your shrink
headed Twitter you think the information
intake is affected the curriculum for
kids I think is it harder as a little
deeper and move faster you think school
yeah yeah that's interesting well the
teachers have decided like they can't
ban phones they just can't cuz it just
it's just not a member that's started
they have to dancing in Kansas you hear
that John let's go if you had a deeper
and your mama to come get it don't take
it when I would isolated okay yeah I got
a cell phone when I was 18 cuz my mom's
work from yeah she's like you're driving
like here you go
it's funny a punishment to take my
daughter's cell phone away at 16 years
old one of the big thing you know also
with the they scare the shitty in the
world that something terrible can happen
that you need her to have her phone you
know she has to be kind of tethered to
it
yeah so we can get ahold of her you know
I mean I get blown away like I get
nervous can't get ahold of her God the
idea of that that if this was you know
25 years ago she'd have to get to a
landline again like every number
you'd have a number to call I mean I
would they've sold the parents that was
like so funny like in case your child is
anywhere they need to get in contact
with you an emergency
and by the way they'll have no privacy
and all the information will be
before everyone is seen to perform their
own lives everyone okay and it's like
wait what like what was that second part
but but the gulf between that and it we
fell down the rabbit hole so quickly
it's so insane I went from being in
seventh grade with my chunky Motorola
phone impressing girls by throwing my
phone over my shoulder and showing that
like it wouldn't shatter oh my god cream
skyhooks it into the dress but yeah it's
it's wild and like the yeah the crazy
thing is that like that just like there
are like what what me up looking
at it which is just so weird is that
they're like and I've been in these
places I mean there are places in
Silicon Valley like you know with 300
employees that they're like the purpose
of their company is to cater to the base
wants of children like like what they
actually program is what kids want like
I don't know a photo service where
photos disappear after 24 hours what
would a kid want that for and what is
maybe like that's sort of legalized
child pornography information they can't
be liable for it because it's
disappearing after 24 you know and
there's no mechanism to ask like this is
good what do they maybe one or we making
like because it's it's it's just so it's
it's so in front of it's so ahead of us
right now that we're like you said we're
falling down the rabbit hole with no
direction so fast and like the
decisions about kids like neural mystery
are being made literally but like
programmers yes I'm just saying that and
they're not social geniuses years and
years ago if your kid was like ahead of
you on technology to worry about I'm
starting war games or something where
it's like now it's it's just flat out
that it's like are they giving their
privacy away are they all your kids
sending but child pornography basically
to each other and that's and they are
ahead of it because we're I think I know
where I go or I would have to check my
daughter's thing see I know there's the
secret apps that are photo apps I know
how to find those things you know
whatever yeah but I don't
she definitely knows 12 more things than
I want to work always a step ahead I
don't know if had a check if she has
more than
on Twitter or instance of the things are
like you yeah you have to be literate in
this whole thing to even understand the
dangerous they're just so strange you
know like so it's it's it's let's go
analog dude I know it's so funny that's
what people say like people say like
people always say to me like there's
gonna be a generation and unplugs I'm
like yeah some things are cyclical like
for sure but sometimes like a car shows
up and there's no more horses
like that that's just what happens yeah
so report things just change and they
and especially like you want to think
this is cyclical and like a generation
will unplug watch a
three-year-old with an iPad it's great
you'll see that like these things are
designed to appeal to us before we can
think that's what I said I had a
bit about that but I did on coding about
just watching a little kid with the
iPads one of the most terrifying
things in the world is a fuss in my
ex-wife yeah has they know how do you
mind blowing my ex-wife has a new baby
so it's my daughter's sister and well if
we go to dinner or something the other
they occupy her by giving her an iPad or
the iPhone yeah and how I'll know if she
has the phone if I'm not with them if
the baby has the foam because what she
knows not only is to go to YouTube they
basically the 4:3 are they set her up
with the page that has all the videos of
that cartoon or whatever as she watches
but she knows how to pick a different
one go to a different one and she knows
if somebody calls and buzzes in that she
has to you know if something comes up
says there's a text she knows how to
swipe it up to make go away and if
someone calls she knows to hit the red
to make it she's three yeah yeah that's
navigator face of YouTube isn't saying
is that this this is the image that like
and I and multiple people have said this
to me I've I know other people with
young kids who have done the exact same
thing
my nephew watches videos there's videos
of um like which is so demented that
these people make these videos of
parents that film their kids playing
with toys it's all about like Geoff's
toys where it's like unwrapping boxes
yeah yes so what happens it's like so
now my sister over people like you know
with her kid and and he'll start playing
with toys and be like mom mom tell them
about the thinking there's an audience
there so talking to we're going tell
them about the tell them to tell them to
subscribe or tell them and in multiple
people I've said have said that that
their kids watch these videos and then
and like they think they're in The
Truman Show exactly and that that is
that is a real sort of like like
depersonalization or whatever like
that's like a real thing that can happen
if he's sure and like but like that's it
sounds like a goofy thing is it like but
that's like a weird Metta strange prison
type of living which i think is what
kids suffer from now which is they don't
just live their life they also hover
over themselves and wash themselves live
there they don't just approach moments
they before they even have a moment
they're wondering what that moment will
be how it'll be looked back on how
people react to how they look back like
you know it's the most on the nose
example that is every concert no we're
not supposed to become shitty New Yorker
cartoons you mean like like the problem
with like the country becoming the movie
idiocracy is like it's not a great movie
like that's but no one's actually saying
is that it's like it's kind of an on the
nose shitty satire movie that it's
insane how much that movie comes up just
in conversation people on a daily basis
right it's every true I said that was it
come out with the UFC fights now yeah
when the UFC when that when Michael
buffer is announcing you go for the main
event he goes we are here at the MGM
Grand
brought to you by you know mojitos when
you're having a rough summer make sure
you drink a mojito brand mojitos
fighting out of the red can get real
dark do to MetroPCS your cancer
diagnosis is in brought to you by
pepto-bismol you got prostate cancer
we have to get we have to get Bo out of
here again the movie eighth-grade out
now available on blu-ray and digital
platforms owns a man dude so great to
see I'm so proud of you man that's what
I was a gem burr how kind you were to me
at that time I remember more than
anybody I specifically say when people
say who was a comedian that was very
nice to you when you were young it was
you you were so make a movie called 41
we'll be right back everybody
it's the bonfire that was so cool talk
to though it did it was a bum-out talk
though just like we're old the young are
the future and they're crazy that's
great the young is into technology
they're robots they don't like you I
don't know if I look at this generation
and go they're gonna fix everything
we gotta let one go maybe they're kids
one generation has to be like on yeah
one generation is gonna suck and then
the next one's gonna be like we got a
clean Isabella's children are
gonna turn already yes your
grandchildren just swiping left and
right
[Music]
you